bonsoir ce soir je vais vous parler d'un
sujet qui me tient particulièrement à
coeur
c'est l'éducation et la curiosité en
préparant ce talk je me suis dit c'est
pas la peine d'utiliser des études et
des statistiques même des citations
aujourd'hui je vais vous donner mes
impressions sur un travail de terrain
que j'ai réalisé avec toute une équipe
l'équipe de l'association en piste
artistes
la première question je me suis posé en
préparant le talk cette haine quelles
sont les choses qui intéressent nos
jeunes aujourd'hui et comme réponse je
vous donnais qui intéresse les jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est des univers des
contextes où l'enfant peut s'exprimer
expérimenté s'épanouir utiliser son
potentiel créatif son potentiel physique
mettre en oeuvre son imagination
ces univers c'est les sports la musique
la danse mais c'est pas seulement ça
aujourd'hui c'est aussi minecraft gta 5
call of duty des jeux vidéos qui sont
dans la chambre de nos enfants ou sur la
télé de la salle à manger des jeux vidéo
ultra addictif ultra violent c'est aussi
la télé réalité secret story les ch'tis
les anges c'est comment dirais-je des
choses qui intéressent nos jeunes c'est
des anonymes qui deviennent célèbres et
qui sont des rôles modèle pour nos
jeunes
il ya aussi youtube où il ya des
millions de vidéos des vidéos qui nous
intéresse et des fois des vidéos qui
nous intéresse pas des vidéos cool des
vidéos dangereuse youtube et il ya aussi
les youtuber s'est dé nouveau gars sont
sortis de youtube il propose des des
vidéos pour nos jeunes il ya les youtube
heures des humoristes sont très très pas
ça
c'est un grand catalyseur les humoristes
il aime bien les jeunes les humoristes
via les gamer nous apprennent encore à
mieux jouer
il ya aussi les les maquilleuses grand
succès aussi très grand succès ensuite
on a fait ce book twitter am stram gram
et snap chatte snapshot le nouveau
phénomène même le gouvernement veut se
lancer sur ce match at et ça ça permet
de mettre notre vie en images ben on
mange on dort toujours sur le téléphone
le point commun toutes ces choses là
c'est que c'est des univers artificiel
c'est des univers artificiel ultra
connectés ils sont ultra connectés mais
il ne déconnecte nous mêmes de la
réalité des vraies choses du monde
naturel de nous mêmes de notre famille
de notre curiosité
c'est des aspirateurs de curiosité ça
mange beaucoup de temps ça mange
beaucoup de temps et ça peut aussi
porter atteinte à nos enfants à nos
jeunes on voit apparaître des problèmes
d'ultraviolence des problèmes
d'expression
l'hypersexualisation des mineurs des
problèmes de concentration
comment captiver la curiosité de nos
jeunes
ça c'est la question que je me suis
posée la première question vous me
supposé en 2009 avant de m'investir dans
une initiative citoyenne de bon sens en
faveur de l'éducation
cette initiative a pour objectif de
collaborer à la construction d'un nouvel
apprentissage
un apprentissage qui capte la curiosité
de nos jeunes donc j'ai créé en piste
artistes avec un pote qui s'appelle
david si dans d'ailleurs la soude pour
lui en pis l'artiste
ces initiatives ils trop ambitieuse mais
c'est très important
c'est très important si demain on va un
citoyen capable d'utiliser son potentiel
créatif pour changer les choses
répondre à des problématiques sociétales
ultra-important écologie économie bon
sens d'humanisme utiliser son potentiel
créatif c'est avoir un regard différent
sur ces choses là pour apporter des
réponses non conventionnelles
du coup j'ai créé cette association qui
a pour objectif de rendre nos enfants
futé un enfant futé on propose une
pédagogie alternative une pédagogie
d'apprentissage par le jeu et la
manipulation
on a démarré avec les tout petits à
partir de 3 ans on leur a proposé des
expositions du dos éducatif comment on
peut trouver dans les grandes instances
comme la cité des sciences où le
vaisseau à strasbourg
des choses comme ça c'est des
expositions où les petits apprennent en
s'amusant
on a en avait à peu près on voyait mille
enfants par an en 2009
ensuite on est on sait très rapidement
attaqué aux écoles élémentaires sur le
temps scolaire sur le temps périscolaire
avec des ateliers nous à l'atelier
ludo-éducatif qu'on a présenté comme des
outils dans lesquels on pouvait inséré
n'importe quelle thématique
alors y avait des ateliers de numérique
cuisine moléculaire sérigraphie
impression on a tout fait on passe dans
tous les domaines et dans ses ateliers
on peut mettre n'importe quelle
thématique on s'est rendu compte que ça
intéressait beaucoup nos enfants ensuite
on a privilégié une pédagogie une
pédagogie d'apprentissage par le jeu
d'apprentissage dans le plaisir
un enfant il aime bien prendre quand il
s'amuse une pédagogie où il ya de la
transversalité par exemple avec une
recette de cuisine on peut voyager dans
l'espace mais aussi dans l'histoire une
pédagogie du livre progrès on peut
prendre un enfant de 6 ans il met avec
un enfant de 12 ans y'a pas de problème
ils vont se poser des questions et ça va
alimenter leur curiosité et une
autonomie co constructive ça veut dire
qu'on trouve des objets qui attire la
curiosité des enfants on leur donne et
bing on disparaît on les laisse discuter
échanger fabriquer expérimentés ensuite
on est passé au collège et au collège on
a vu apparaître des phénomènes un peu
bizarre
des problèmes de comportement
d'absentéisme de décrochage scolaire
d'orientation je trouve c'est un réel
gaspillage de potentiel pourquoi les
enfants ne sont plus curieux à l'école
ça c'est une bonne question
les enfants ne sont plus curieux à
l'école enfin je vous donne ma version
des choses
les personnels je pense que le système
éducatif dans sa globalité voit l'enfant
comme un ordinateur super intelligent
dans lequel il faut insérer des
programmes des programmes avec des mises
à jour
des plugins des groupes d'experts
l'enseignant comment je le vois sont pas
tous comme ça ça manque de diversité
pédagogique mois l'enseignant je le vois
comme un pilote de rallye faut qu'ils
arrivent à l'heure il fait une course
contre le temps
une course autant il doit transmettre
ces programmes il doit transmettre ses
contenus coûte que coûte à la fin de
l'année ils courent contre le temps et
du coup il se concentre plus sur les
contenus que sur la stratégie
d'apprentissage la réussite scolaire
c'est pas forcément avoir des bonnes
notes c'est pas forcément finir en
premier la réussite scolaire s'est
trouvé sa vocation être curieux aller
chercher plus loin
en fait la curiosité c'est quoi la
curiosité c'est à la base de toutes les
découvertes
c'est une envie une fin une soif
d'apprendre de comprendre de savoir la
curiosité c'est quelque chose de naturel
plus on est curieux que l'on apprend
deux choses plus on apprend des choses
qu'on est capable de les lier entre
elles qu'on est capable de les lier
entre elles l'ont et créatif la
curiosité alimente la créativité ni la
curiosité ni la créativité sont des
questions d'intellect je pense que c'est
des questions de contexte faut savoir
mettre l'enfant dans un contexte de
liberté créative qui préserve sa
sensibilité sa simplicité sa spontanéité
sa curiosité et sa c'est le but de en
pis l'artiste alors quelles sont les
grandes portes d'entrée de la curiosité
comment on peut rendre curieux quelqu'un
vous rendre curieux quelqu'un sait
capter son attention mais la plus grande
porte d'entrée de la curiosité pour moi
c'est la surprise
l'émerveillement quand on est surpris ou
émerveillé c'est comme dans un tour de
magie on va dire il ya un magicien il a
un chapeau il sort en lapins oies
comment a fait le gars
et là on passe d'un esprit passif à un
esprit actifs et on va aller chercher la
réponse on va être curieux de trouver
cette réponse par par nous mêmes et ça
c'est ultra important être curieux aussi
réveillé sa curiosité c'est l'art de
poser la bonne question
la bonne question à l'être humain mais
aussi aux moteurs de recherche
parce qu'à aller à l'époque peut-être
qu'on était plus curieux à l'école parce
que c'était l'endroit où pouvait obtenir
un maximum de questions opposant des
réponses mais aujourd'hui si je me pose
une question
la majorité des gens vont faire quoi
vont sortir leur smartphone ils vont
taper sur google le maître n'est plus
détenteur du savoir le numérique
le tout sans fil ça peut être des super
pouvoirs
mais ça peut être aussi un bâton de
dynamite dans la main d'un enfant tout
le monde est concerné par l'éducation
on doit sensibiliser les enfants au
numérique à l'utilisation du numérique
on doit lui offrir une capacité de
discernement à savoir c'est bon pour moi
c'est pas bon pour moi ça m'aide à me
construire et ça ça m'aide à me détruire
c'est pas trop une aide être curieux
c'est quelque chose de naturel
c'est tout ce que n'a pas un ordinateur
on peut regarder cette image la
curiosité ça se voit dans les yeux d'un
enfant et nous on s'endort un petit peu
tous chaque jour un peu plus et on doit
se réveiller
on doit réveiller notre curiosité et ça
passe par la désacralisation des
pratiques
on doit être curieux on doit trouver des
outils qui nous permettent de
désacraliser les pratiques il faut pas
dire je ne suis pas un musicien je ne
suis pas un penseur
je ne suis pas danseur je ne suis pas
ingénieur en informatique
il faut trouver ces outils qui
permettent aux enfants de devenir
attentif de devenir curieux de trouver
leur vocation et je pense que c'est le
vrai rôle de l'éducation de l'école des
parents
les grands frères des animateurs des
enseignants vous dire une dernière
phrase c'est comme un enfant émerveillé
n'arrêtait jamais de vous poser des
questions
n'arrêtez jamais d'être curieux le monde
entier vous appartient nous sommes là
pour découvrir apprendre enquêter
inventé merci